good evening thanks for joining us at
11. you've seen it in the headlines
right here on channel 8 deadly crash
after deadly crash just over the weekend
police identifying now the motorcyclist
killed in a crash on saturday as
35-year-old morgan arvizo from ely metro
says he was hit by someone who was
driving a pickup truck near north rancho
and vegas drive they tell us the driver
of that truck took off but was later
found and showed signs of impairment
that person was booked into the clark
county detention center on dui and hit
and run and another crash this one from
friday the man in this deadly incident
has been identified as 21-year-old noah
mcfaun police say he crashed with a
tesla on town center drive near gardens
park the investigation there is still
underway the metro says they don't
believe impairment was a factor
so what does our law enforcement have to
say about this and how are locals who
have seen it firsthand coping with it
madison kimbrough spoke to metro police
along with residents in the valley she
joins us now live tonight with more
madison
denise we're here on desert inn and
maryland parkway and as you can see
behind me a car slammed right into this
apartment complex that you're looking at
right now you see where it's boarded up
in that area the people living around
here say it's a hot spot for speeding
cars and the number of fatal collisions
across the valley like you mentioned is
growing rapidly
in the last month
we've had an accident right here like
canada we had somebody hit this building
three days ago
take out part of the support wall in
these apartments across the street
all hours of the day and night
motorcycles las vegas resident joe
vaughn recalling a scary crash in his
neighborhood when a car slammed right
into the wall of an apartment complex
just last week on memorial day right
across the street from where he lives on
desert inn and maryland parkway and
unfortunately this isn't an isolated
incident as vehicle fatalities are on
the rise across the valley according to
metro police we are seeing more fatal
collisions whether it's from bad driving
road construction people just becoming
angrier i can't say for certain the
lbapd has seen 65
fatal collisions this year to date in
only our jurisdiction that does not
incorporate henderson north las vegas or
the nevada state police and to put that
into perspective at this point in 2021
there were 57 fatal collisions within
metro's jurisdiction as for the causes
one of the biggest factors is excessive
speed
we've seen an increase of 71 percent
compared to this point last year deaths
among pedestrians also up from this
point last year by about 26 percent
and as you can see the lower half of the
building is still boarded up the driver
that crashed the vehicle was found dead
on scene but no one inside of the
complex was hurt in the crash those
residents are still displaced reporting
live near desert inn in maryland madison
kimbrough live local now
fact the nation overall is seeing an
increase in certain types of crash
deaths speeding related deaths have been
increasing for the last two years up 22
percent according to the federal highway
administration also going up
alcohol-related deaths they're up about
21 percent in the last two years experts
also say there's been a spike in people
dying because they or someone else in
the car was not wearing a seat belt